This video is brought to you by Skillshare
What's up wisecrack Michael,
here to talk about a brilliant film that captivated fans,
wooed the critics and off. And no one just kidding. I mean the live action film,
the last Airbender based on the very popular, very good Nickelodeon show,
avatar, this film seemingly had everything going for us. Great characters,
a compelling story. And of course, live action fire bending.
So why is this film more cringe, inducing than having your blood bet?
How does the guy who did this?
I see.
Royally screw up source material as truly great as avatar. Anytime a movie,
confounds our expectations like this,
we're forced to pull out our detectives pipe and start puffing until we either
get cancer or figure out what the hell happened.
Special outfit hadn't pipe. These things mean anything to you.
So welcome to this widespread condition on the last Airbender,
what went wrong and of course, spoilers ahead for a bad movie and a good show.
But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor Skillshare.
When I first started writing video scripts for YouTube,
I was a bit unsure of myself.
It was a completely new and fun way to put my ideas into words,
but I wasn't sure if it was coming across on screen.
I researched other YouTubers and submitted script after script to our content
team for feedback,
I really wished I had a partner or community who knew how I was feeling about my
work. And I definitely should have looked to Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community where curious creators come together
to improve their skills.
They offer thousands of inspiring classes for writing photography,
freelancing design,
and more members have the opportunity to share their work with their class
through projects and discussion boards.
I wish I had known that Skillshare offers a course literally called going viral,
right film and make content people share where Matt Bellicide teaches you.
How to create your own voice while balancing relatability don't make the same
mistake I did. And check it out today. For a limited time,
you can use the link in our description for a free trial of Skillshare premium
membership. Now, back to the show, let's do a quick recap.
The film like the TV show that inspired it introduces us to siblings,
Saka and Katara to water tribe, youngsters,
whose dad's off warring against the evil fire nation. While hunting,
they stumble upon a bald kid, frozen in ice. Instead of running away screaming,
they take him under their wing. Then Mike drop.
It turns out he's the avatar,
a Messiah figure who has the ability to bend all four elements, normie benders,
like Tara can only do one loss for a century.
This ice kid Ang is responsible for keeping the four kingdoms in harmony.
But first he's got to learn how to bend all the elements, Katara, Soka,
and Ang set off on a journey to help the young avatar master his powers.
While also fending off the fire nation simultaneously the very moody disgraced
fire print, Zuko hatches, a plan he wants to capture Ang like some stick trophy,
thus restoring his reputation and winning back his father's love at which point
he will presumably stop sulking. Now, quick caveat.
There are a lot of things wrong with the Airbender. For one,
the characters are almost systematically stripped of their endearing qualities.
SACA sense of humor is gone and eggs. Carefree sense of fun is undetectable.
What's more of the stakes are never made urgent or clear enough.
And Ang never really struggles to beat his opponents. And importantly,
anchor character arc is murky at best on the show.
He struggles quite compellingly with guilt about the death of his people and
anxiety about the demands of his title,
that culminates invisible character growth in the movie,
his arc doesn't unfold with the same clarity and resonance there kind of just
isn't time.
Then there's the fact that the show makes a point to show a rich world with all
kinds of cultures and peoples,
whether it's the influence of Southeast Asia seen in the fire nation,
in UIC cultures, in the water nation, Buddhism and the air benders,
or even these Florida inspired swamp people.
You want me to eat? Oh, slim. He's like a member of the family.
The richness of each culture to picked it is a big part of what fans loved about
the show. The movie on the other hand,
cast its protagonist in such a way as to make the central conflict look kind of
like a race war casting aside.
I think this film is actually a great lesson and one of the central problems in
any adaptation,
how do you shorten a lengthy book or television series under the runtime of a
movie and still make something enjoyable? Obviously it's been done,
especially with books.
You don't hear a lot of complaints about Jurassic park fight club or a clockwork
orange.
The last Airbender in a somewhat Herculean adaptation challenge had to fit nine
ish hours of television content into a feature film to stay somewhat faithful to
the show which it does in its own very flawed way.
The film needs to function like an abridged version,
squeezing in the most important thought events so that it starts and ends at
approximately the same point. Luckily,
there's one screenwriting tool that will let you breeze right through all the
complicated information exposition,
but it's a dangerous tool at best in storytelling.
Exposition is any information that flushes out the rules of the world explains
the characters, motivations and so on. If I kill you, that's an action.
If I tell you,
I want to kill you because you murdered my father that's exposition.
My name is [inaudible]. You killed my father.
Prepare to die.
Sometimes exposition is extremely memorable, very iconic,
But more often than not.
Action is more fun to watch flip through any decent book on screenwriting.
And you'll find a section warning,
young writers that bad exposition has an apocalyptic effect on your career.
Anytime a bad piece of dialogue makes you cringe because it sounds wooden falls
and maybe a little embarrassing for the actor.
It's often the result of poorly executed experts.
You've never been stung by a bee, have you? No, no.
Bees are genetically designed to recognize royalty.
Proper exposition is a necessary evil in any narrative work,
but there's an infinite number of ways to convey this information.
It takes us scene long montage to establish that,
say Rocky trained a lot to get in shape it.
Would've taken two seconds to say I worked out a bunch and now I'm in shape,
but the universe would have been robbed of this glory. Exposition is a struggle.
Every screenwriter grapples with, and sometimes it can really work.
I don't like sand. Just kidding, maybe more like this.
But until that day,
except this justice as a gift on my daughter's wedding day.
The last Airbender, unfortunately it has a lot more of those.
They're eating her. I'm not going eat me
and less of the you're a wizard Harry.
Now that we've looked at some examples,
let's see how Sean Alon does exactly what every screenwriting teacher begs his
novice students. Not to do.
It's telling instead of showing exposition tells us things. Yeah.
This is my father.
Characters actions show us things. This boy running to embrace. His father,
communicates everything we need to know without that pointless introduction,
bad movies like this one, chronically tell us things.
Instead of showing them to us.
In my rate of the great library earlier this year,
I found a scroll that tells the location of the ocean and moon spirits.
Why is exposition such a narrative kick in the nuts?
According to screenwriting guru, John York, the problem is really simple.
Most dramatic fiction demands plausibility for characters and not to say things
they wouldn't say in real life. However,
characters also need to impart essential information for the audience's benefit.
That is no believable. Character says hello, brother,
to whom I lent my Nintendo switch last week or wherever have you put it instead?
They'd probably say yo hat. Where's my switch. This though,
a natural and reasonable reaction could leave the audience confused as Yorke
explains.
Exposition can be awkward to present because it rarely occurs in real life to
bring it back to the last Airbender.
Nobody would actually say fire nation is here. Instead.
They'd grab the princess's hand and start running for their freaking lives.
Examples like this are more rampant in this film than COVID-19 at the university
of Alabama roll tide, but first a quick caveat.
The show avatar as amazing as it is,
is not innocent of all expository sins.
Sage is tell us that the avatar is the last Airbender.
He must be over a hundred years old by now.
He's had a century to master the four elements.
We would never make a video ranting about it.
There are a few reasons why first we're talking about an animated kid show that
explicitly does not take itself very seriously.
As a result, its expositional statements come off as far less.
It's walking water mixed together. It means our way out.
Aided by its hyper expressive animation style.
The film in contrast and perhaps out of necessity is just a lot more serious and
it can't get away with the same childlike use of earnest exposition.
All that time. Searching for a teacher I'm finally starting.
What's more. The show uses slightly exposition,
mostly in attempts to create a coherent viewing experience and keep kids engaged
week after week. Even if they happen to forget the whole deal.
When his dad Zuko had shown shameful weakness as
punishment, he was banished and sent to capture the avatar.
Movie. On the other hand,
regularly repeats information as if the audience is suffering from amnesia.
In our final defense of the show,
it's expository elements tend to lean hard into emotion and motivation.
The TV show brilliantly balances exposition with emotion information is conveyed
to characters. During scenes filled with conflict.
Their reactions tend to render the exposition almost invisible.
You are the Airbender, your the avatar,
no way.
In contrast the film's expositional sins come in two distinct flavors,
voiceover and on-screen dialogue.
Voiceover is the nuclear reactor of screenwriting exposition used with care.
It can be incredibly effective and efficient.
The man for his time and place.
He fits right in there and that's the dude used
incorrectly.
It'll blow up your entire script.
Tyrella told me Rachel was special, no termination date.
I didn't know how long we'd have together.
Screenwriting expert hall, Ackerman, warns that any time you use such a device,
voiceover flashbacks, you are calling attention to it as a device and one,
you had better use it effectively. And two,
it had better be the best way of telling the story. If that's the case,
what is the purpose of voiceover? According to Ackerman,
it serves like a portal into the characters.
Psyche making us privy to their inner thoughts,
which would otherwise be inaccessible.
Enter Kotara our narrator from the get-go the movie piggybacks off the TV shows
intro,
which features are 45 seconds efficient narration that ends with powerful,
emotional insight into her character.
But I believe Ang can save the world.
Movie guitarra is a little less economical. Let's look at a sample line.
The scroll we had was proving to be helpful, almost practicing,
Oh wait, it, it keeps going. We try to stay out of sight,
but soca became concerned. We were being followed.
Guitarist, voiceover functions, like the Wikipedia plot summary,
like the rest of her duration.
It gives us precisely zero information about her emotional state.
According to Ackerman successful voiceover works.
When it shows us a different person.
After that you invent the spending, the abuse,
the fear, the threat of violence.
This is the case when a character is being dishonest with the audience or the.
Selves basic took great care and reviving him.
Look, it's hard as voiceover doesn't elucidate,
any internal struggles or reveal anything new about herself or even about her
deep faith. Yeah.
Flew us to his home. He told us how he left there in a storm on opera.
Here, voiceovers merely piece of duct tape over the torn fabric of the plot.
Showed them.
He was the last Airbender and was accepted to train with the master.
Throughout. We see information conveyed through voiceover. Yeah.
My brother and I often go hunting for food,
but unfortunately my brother isn't the best Hunter in the world.
Rather than shown through action as it is on the show.
It's not getting away from me this time
In the film, painful information can be conveyed through clinical narration.
My mother was taken prisoner and killed. When I was young.
On the show, it's organic resulting from a heated confrontation.
I've been doing all the work around camp while you've been off playing soldier.
It's more good. Voiceover is often compelling because it's motivated.
A given character has a reason for dispensing this piece of information.
The most common way to do this is through the use of a storybook narrator I've
seen in just about every Disney movie, modern audiences,
maybe less compelled by Cinderella's plates,
but the device creatively used certainly can still work.
Boy, that's going to happen.
But filmmakers have gotten creative with voiceover throughout the years.
For example,
in the classic new are double indemnity voiceover functions as a recorded
confession to a crime indeed successful noir films,
very often employee superb voiceover that adds to the characters,
complexity or reveals their subjectivities. Sometimes rendering them unreliable.
I saw him once he was dead, he fell out of the car.
This makes it tense and dynamic.
The last air benders narration in comparison is flatwood and it just kind of
lazy.
Leave the child. Avatar has only knowledge of his birth element air.
Let's move on to perhaps the greatest sin in the last Airbender.
The dialogue now dialogue is frequently used as exposition and film,
but what distinguishes good expositional dialogue from bed? According to York,
good exposition is disguised by making it dramatic by injecting conflict,
the greater the conflict, the less visible the exposition.
As an example of successful dialogue, he cites apocalypse now,
which cramps in entire films worth of exposition into one brisk scene.
Did you not assassinate a government tax collector country province June 18,
1968.
The result as Yorke explains the scene managers to incorporate subtext desire,
conflict,
and the deeply personal to get across almost every fact the film needs in order
to be understood.
The characters evasiveness gives us just as much exposition as the interviewer's
purely informative questions. In contrast,
the last Airbender tends to rely on conflict free exposition.
As when Katara blatantly pumps her grandma for information.
What is a spiritual grandma?
The result is boring and static.
There are no stakes to the reveal of any piece of information.
That little boy might be the avatar.
Grandma and Katara.
Both think this kid is the avatar and what's more both in Katara and Saka need
to leave the village to help him Katara to convince socket,
but it's still pretty low conflict.
Contrast this with similarly things encounters on the show were in Kitara and
grand grand disagree about whether eggs, the avatars.
I told you, he's the real thing. Grand grant.
I finally found a bender to teach me.
FITARA try not to put all your hopes in this boy.
These tense moments are expository and that they give background information.
Clearly guitarra has been searching and waiting to find someone to teach her
these moments culminate in guitar,
choosing to go exploring with Ang largely in defiance of her grandma.
Although grand grand eventually gives her blessing all resulting in a compelling
emotional arc and contrast film guitar leaves the village with zero emotional
tension or steaks we're going with let's compare another plot point when Ang
finds out that the air nomads were killed by the fire news in both the movie and
the show guitar tries to warn Ang about what to expect when they get to the
Southern air temple, but on the show after Katara, his worst fears are proven,
right? The air nomads are dead. She starts to tell him.
There's something you need to see. Okay,
what is it? Uh, just a new water bending move. I learned.
Guitar tries to hide a painful truth. Ang temple was destroyed by fire vendors.
Meanwhile, anxious, trying to figure out what the F happened to his home.
This setup innately bigs conflict into the reveal of this information.
The helmet becomes a ticking time bomb. And when Ang learns the truth,
we're too wrapped up in the emotions to realize that we are being given crucial
background information. In contrast,
the truth comes out pretty seamlessly in the film with guitar, eagerly,
volunteering, all the information and needs.
The fire nation knew the avatar would be born into the air nomads.
But our greatest grievance with last Airbender is the way it deals with Ang
central conflict.
Whether or not he can be slash is ready to be slash even wants to be the avatar
in both the show and the movie.
It takes some time to find out why Ang was in the ice.
That is because he ran away from his duties as the avatar. However, in the film,
this information is revealed quite readily and without.
I ran away before they trained me.
Confession should be huge. Instead it's accepted by everyone.
Pretty much without reaction in contrast on the show,
Ang tells the truth after prodding from Katara and only to correct her missed
assumption.
You have a right to be angry after the monks sent you away like that. Well,
that's not exactly what happened. He admitted slowly.
I was afraid confused. I didn't know what to do.
What's more, he lets Katara like the audience, put the pieces together, herself,
creating a much more dynamic. Those still expository scene. You ran away.
The last Airbender film seems self-conscious about its over-reliance and
exposition. And sometimes the script almost tries to repent. For example,
you see the writer trying to create a compelling reason to tell us about Zuko is
banishment first via his rivalry with general shout.
No followed is burnished his son, the Prince, and renounced.
His love of him and will not let him return to the throne unless he finds the
avatar.
Line, reveals its own redundancy is ya'll literally says as you know,
rendering the dialogue self-consciously unnecessary. Then the film in parts,
almost the exact same information. Just minutes later,
when Zuko gets a little boy to retell the story of his banishment.
Tell me what you know about the Prentice fire.
Here. There's no reason why Zuko needs to hear his own life story.
It's lamely justified by the fact that he's trying to explain to his uncle why
he can't party and meet cute girls.
He's been disgraced and must regain his honor. However,
there's no tension to the reveal of his backstory and it mostly amounts to what
Ackerman calls a big vomit pale of information in a remarkably on the nose
moment, near the end of the film, Ang begs the dragon spirit for help.
Please tell me how to beat the fire.
The spirit replies who's the ocean.
Show them the power of water.
It's a little ironic that the tension between showing and telling comes up in
the literal dialogue of the film.
If only the writer had taken the dragon spirits own advice and shown rather than
told us Ang story, but what do you guys think?
Are we being too harsh on a film so bad?
It's two sequels were promptly abandoned.
Let us know in the comments as always big,
thanks to our patrons for your support. Go ahead and bend that subscribe button.
Like it's the blood of your enemy. And as always, thanks for watching.
Later,
[inaudible].